Chào mừng anh em đã đến với video ngày
hôm nay. Google Anti Gravity từng là một
ID khá là hot của Google được rất nhiều
anh em đép tin dùng và sử dụng nhưng mà
rất nhiều anh em không biết cách chưa sử
dụng đúng cách và chưa tối ưu hết hiệu
năng của con AI agent này khiến Output
chưa được như ý muốn.
Thì trong video ngày hôm nay em sẽ hướng
dẫn mọi người cách sử dụng con AI agent
này kết hợp với RU WF follow và skill để
tối ưu được
một kết quả như mong đợi.
Thì trước hết thì mọi người phải có lên
web và download con Anti Gravity này về.
thì mọi người có thể lên web gõ download
antigravity và truy cập vào trang web
chính thức của Google như ở trên màn
hình em đã share đây và bấm vào
download.
Ở đây thì sẽ có ba version cho các hệ
điều hành khác nhau Maos, Windows và
Linux. Thì hiện tại mình đang dùng B OS
nên là mình sẽ download for Apple
Silicon.
Thì hiện tại ở đây thì em đã có cài đặt
sẵn về anti Gravity rồi nên là em sẽ mở
luôn lên để sử dụng và setup cho nó
nhanh.
Mọi người chỉ cần thực hiện down về và
setup cài đặt bình thường để sử dụng
antigravity nhé.
Thì sau đấy thì mình sẽ khi mà download
thành công và tải về thì mình sẽ có một
giao diện như màn hình này thì giao diện
của Antigravity này nó sẽ khá giống với
X VS Code, Visual Studio Code nên là
mình sẽ làm quen khá là nhanh.
Trong này thì em đã thực hiện thiết
các rule skill workfollow rồi. Và các
thành phần này thì mình sẽ đi qua một
vòng trước để tìm hiểu về nó và cách
hoạt động của nó như thế nào.
Thì hiện tại ở đây thì với ru thì đúng
theo nghĩa của nó. Ru là gì? Ru chuyện
khi dịch sang tiếng Anh nó cũng đã là
luật rồi là thì đúng với nghĩa cái đen
của nó thì nó là luật là một dàng buộc
cố định cho con AI agent hoạt động. Khi
mà mình tạo ra ru ấy thì con AI agent sẽ
dựa vào cái ru này triển khai các tác
các công việc mà được mình giao cho dựa
trên cái xương sống là cái ru này. Thì ở
đây em đã có viết à ở đây mình đã có
viết về các một sẵn một ru với
dep web thì ru này có các
tính năng sau.
Mọi người có thể đọc và tham khảo trước
để hiểu về hơn về RU.
Thì RU này thì hiểu nôm na với ngoài đời
như kiểu là luật pháp của mình và ừ hoặc
là trong công ty thì nó là luật và các ờ
điều khoản cho công ty. Bắt buộc mình
phải thực hành theo với mọi công việc.
Đấy thì ở đây thì với một web design thì
trong rule này nó đang đưa ra những cái
quy luật để khi mà AI agent thực hiện
tác sẽ luôn phải thực hiện theo những
cái đấy. Thứ nhất là chuyên lý về thiết
kế này. Hai bô cục này, khoảng cách. Ba
là kiểu chữ bốn là hệ thống màu sắc. Cái
thứ năm là hiệu ứng và chiều sâu của UI.
Thứ sáu là hoạt ảnh và tương tác phi mô.
Bảy là thiết kế đáp ứng. tám là mẫu
thành phần giao diện và có các thêm nữa
hình ảnh đa phương tiện và khả năng truy
cập và tối ưu công cụ tìm kiếm cấu trúc
của mã nguồn như nào đây thì đây là cơ
bản thì là một ru của web design hoặc là
với các
app mobile thì mình cũng sẽ có những cái
cấu trúc như kiểu clean architect mvm
ờ các cách xử lý life cycle như thế nào.
Đấy thì đấy là cơ bản là những cái bao
quát, tổng quát mà gây dựng lên được web
hoặc là gây dựng lên các app mobile thì
đấy gọi là RU. Mình sẽ đặt ở trong RU là
cái xương sống để con AI agent dựa theo
đấy để phát triển lên được
công việc của mình các web hoặc là các
app mobile thì
tiếp theo là đến Wordfollow. Workfollow
thì ở đây workfollow là các bước, các
quy trình mà con Asian AI thực hiện theo
từng tính năng, từng future.
Thì ở đây để lấy ví dụ kỹ hơn thì mình
đã soạn sẵn một cái workflow là plan.
Nghĩa là cái workflow này sẽ thực hiện
theo kế hoạch mà theo kế hoạch ý tưởng
mà bạn đưa ra cho con AI agent. Ví dụ
mình có một ý tưởng là ờ hãy lên cho tôi
một ờ landing page đi thì con khi mình
gọi plan này ra thì nó sẽ thực hiện như
thế nào? Thì thứ nhất, bước thứ nhất
workfollow ấy nó sẽ liệt kê ra các bước.
Thì cái quy trình plan này của mình nó
có ba bước. Bước thứ nhất là lên
brainstoring. Bắt buộc bắt buộc con AI
agent phải thực hiện động não, thực hiện
nghĩ suy nghĩ thh kinh về cái ý tưởng
đấy. Làm như nào để đưa ra cho mình
những cái câu hỏi liệt kê các US cần
thiết ờ đưa ra ý tưởng cho mình để hoàn
tiện được cái
tác mà mình giao cho nó. Đây thì mọi
người có thể đọc qua đây. Đây là lot
learning liên quan. Learning phần
learning này là mình phần mình đã thiết
kế là khi mà con AI agent thực hiện xong
tag thì nó sẽ tự nó sẽ thực hiện tóm tắt
lại cái conversion đấy và thực hiện tóm
tắt lại cái tag đấy để lưu lại làm một
file learning.
Sau đấy nếu mà có những cái tác mà nó
liên quan tới cái phần learning mà đã
thực hiện lưu ở định phần trước ấy thì
nó sẽ gọi cho nó đọc thì nó sẽ hiểu hơn
được cái context, hiểu hơn được cái code
và cái report của mình hơn. Nó sẽ thực
hiện brainstorming thực hiện lên kế
hoạch ấy. Thì ở đây thì nó sẽ bước thứ
hai thì nó sẽ gọi brainstoring này,
skill này ra. Phần skill này thì em sẽ
giới thiệu sau ở phần một chút nữa. Thì
sau khi nó tìm hiểu về ý tưởng, thực
hiện suy nghĩ kinh rồi lên kế hoạch thì
nó sẽ đưa ra mình cho đưa mình cho mình
một plan. plan sau khi mà đưa ra plan
đấy thì nó sẽ
thực hiện exc cái tag đấy. Sau verify
sau đấy thì bước cuối cùng thì nó sẽ
thực hiện lưu lại cái
mà AI agent đấy đã thực hiện được. với
cái code của mình và nó sẽ học lại nó sẽ
tổng hợp lại một file learning để sau
nếu mình có sử dụng hoặc là làm tới một
cái chức năng nào đấy liên quan tới cái
chức năng A B đã thực hiện ở trước thì
con AI này sẽ tự động đắp vào đấy.
Đây là plan mọi người có thể lên các
plan khác như kiểu hỗ trợ ví dụ chuyển
tội từ code A, ngôn ngữ code A sang code
B thì bước một cần làm gì, bước hai cần
làm gì, bước ba cần làm gì. Đấy thì đấy
là work word work follow mọi người cần
làm để thực hiện theo để con AI agent nó
biết và thực hiện theo các bước đấy.
Rồi thì đấy là cơ bản là về ờ group
follow là như vậy. Thì bước thứ ba,
skill. Skill ở đây là gì? Ờ skill ở đây
là một cái
năng lực đóng gói chuyên môn của con AI
agent. Đó ví dụ là con AI này được lạp
vào 1000 tỷ thứ của của các dòng code
của các chuyên môn công nghệ thông tin
nhưng mà khi mà nó sử dụng một tác ấy
thì nó chỉ cần sử dụng một cái
ừ kỹ năng cơ bản thôi hoặc ví dụ là nó
làm web thì lúc đấy nó chỉ cần sử dụng
cái kỹ năng của nó là web thôi. Nhưng mà
vì nó đạp được quá nhiều thông tin, nó
đang bị loãng thông tin nên là nó sẽ
không sử dụng được đúng cái mà contex
ngữ cảnh của nó để nó làm được cái ư tác
mà mình đưa cho. Thế nên là mình sẽ tự
định hướng cho nó những cái skill. Cái
skill này là cái nhỏ nhỏ nhất về những
chuyên môn. Ví dụ web có web design này,
web code này, web review này, web debug
này. Đấy thì mình sẽ define ra những cái
skill đấy để dành cho riêng chuyên môn
của con AI agent. Khi mình sử dụng mình
gán vào thì con AI agent này nó sẽ làm
việc được chuyên nghiệp hơn. Và đây để
đi vào tìm hiểu sâu hơn nữa thì mình sẽ
lại cũng đi vào những cái AI cái skill
em đã chuẩn bị sẵn.
Thì ở đây mình đang ờ với là một code
thì mình đang có sự hay sử dụng những
cái skill này. Và skill này tí mình sẽ
chia sẻ lại cho mọi người. Skill này thì
mình đang có sử dụng cái sử dụng mình sử
dụng nhiều nhất đó chính là
brainstorming. Thứ hai là code review và
cái thứ ba là bug. Đấy thì giới thiệu
qua và đọc qua về xem là cái skill này
nó đã làm gì để làm gì. Thì skill đây
thì cái skill này nó là tiếng Anh nhưng
mà mình sẽ chuyển sang tiếng Việt rồi
cho mọi người dễ đọc. Skill này có được
cung cấp ở trên trang GH tí mình sẽ giới
thiệu thêm. Giờ mình sẽ đi tìm hiểu là
skill này dùng để làm gì đã. Thì skill
này brainstoring đây. Descption của nó
chuyển đổi một ý tưởng mơ hồ thành thiết
kế đã được xác nhận thông qua lập luận
có kỷ luật và cộng tác. Thì đấy thì cái
description của này đã nói lên là để nó
làm gì rồi là để nó chuyển cái ý tưởng m
hồ của mình. Ví dụ mình chỉ cần mình có
một cái ý tưởng là lên landing page đi
nhưng mà nó sẽ đi chuyên sâu và phân
tích là landing page này cần những thông
tin gì, bán về sản phẩm gì, quảng cáo
cho brand nào các thứ. Đây cái đ cái đấy
thì đây thì đi vào thì bước đầu tiên là
nó chuyển đổi ý tưởng thì thiết kế. thì
đi vào mục đích. Mục đích ở đây là gì?
Mục đích là chuyển đổi ý tượng thu thành
thiết kế và đạ đặc tả rõ ràng đã được
xác nhận
thông qua chuyển thông qua đối thoại qua
cấu trúc trước khi bắt đầu bất kỳ triển
khai nào đấy. Khi mình gọi skill này ra
thì nó sẽ thực hiện suy nghĩ hết xây
dựng xây dựng cho mình các a
lên kế hoạch cho mình chế độ hoạt động
như nào quy trình. Quy trình ở đây thì
nó gồm bảy bước thì mọi người có thể đọc
thêm ở trong này để hiểu được là quy
trình nó làm từng bước từng bước một để
là hiểu và lên kế hoạch cho mình
bảy bước. Đấy, sau khi xong, sau khi
thiết kế xong các sau khi thực hiện theo
quy trình trên xong bảy bước thì nó sẽ
đưa ra cho mình một cái tài liệu
ban giao. Và khi mà đã hoàn tất đủ các
bước trên thì nó sẽ đánh giá tiêu chí
thoát và thoát.
tiêu chí thoát và đã đưa cho mình một
plan ấy và để thoát khỏi vòng lạp không
thình kinh nữa, không suy nghĩ nữa. Đây
đây nó cũng có luôn là khi nào sử dụng
đây. Ở đây thì sẽ có hai hướng ờ khi mà
mình code thì một thứ nhất là mình có
thể mình không biết gì về cái tác đấy
thì mình có thể dùng mình cái tác đấy
mình rất mơ hồ rất ít thông tin thì mình
có thể sử dụng brainstoring nó sẽ vạch
cho mình kế hoạch từ A đến Z. Cái quan
trọng nhất là bạn phải trị ra được là
mình cần làm gì, output của mình là gì
thì đấy thì nó sẽ vạch một đường đi từ A
đến B cho mình sau qua các dễ nhánh nó
sẽ đi được đến B.
Đấy thì là mình sẽ dùng skin này. Còn
nếu mà mình ờ có ý tưởng, có lập luận
logic rồi thì mình nên sẽ chia theo kiểu
là ờ ừ mình hỏi nó để nó trả lời, để nó
phân tích về các skill à về để nó phân
tích về các tác, các ý tưởng đấy cho
mình xem có chuẩn không, xem có clear
không, xem có bị hỏng ở chỗ nào, thiếu
cây ở chỗ nào không. Đấy, đây là các
skill. Còn chức năng skill code review
này thì nó cũng tương tự thôi. Nó chỉ là
một d chức năng duy nhất là code review
à nó review lại code của mình.
Đây mọi người có thể lên đây đọc thử. Và
những cái skill này không phải là do em
tự à không phải do mình tự viết mà là do
mình em lấy ở trên
antiravity.
Đây thì
ừ mô hình skill này mình sẽ gửi lại tất
cả mọi mọi người ở dưới video. Thì
GitHub này repo này được 35.000 sao khá
nhiều người tin tưởng và sử dụng và nó
cung cấp tới 1435
agent skill cho tất cả các anh em agent
hoặc là ờ anh em làm văn phòng nhẹ nhàng
thôi cũng có. Tất cả mọi skill đều có đủ
hết ở trong này. Thì để clon được cái
repo này về để sử dụng và add vào trong
antiravity thì đây có tất cả clot code
gemini
code x antigravity thì đây mình đọc
antigravity rồi thì mình có lấy cái dòng
lệnh này
mình vứt vào install
và đợi nó chạy
Đấy. Đây sau khi mà đã tải thành công
thì sẽ thông có một thông báo là in
installer to thư mục của mình thì mình
sẽ giữ mình sẽ để phần này nhá. Đừng
đừng đóng vội để tí mình sẽ có việc cần
dùng đến th part này. Đây mình copy copy
Ctrl C vào copy.
Sau khi copy xong rồi thì mình đóng cũng
được. Sau đó mình sẽ vào anti Gravity
mình mở anti lên. Có một cái phần custom
open antiravity user setting đây. Sau đó
mình sẽ vào phần customization.
Và đây mình sẽ thêm bấm nút S. Mình thêm
cái part vừa được
tải về được tải hết tất cả các skill về
mình sử dụng. Mình bấm vào đây enter thì
nó sẽ thêm tất cả các skill có trong cái
mục chứa lại cho mình. Nghĩa là vừa mình
xem trên repo là có 1400
skill agent. Thì hiện tại là trong
antigravity này của mình đã chứa được
1400 skill rồi. Sau đó mình mình mới
thực hiện reload lại. Lúc này là
antiravity đã nhận rồi. Mình có thể ra
ngoài này kiểm tra bật agent lên gõ thử
xộc.
Đây mình đã nhận được tất cả các skill ở
trên repo rồi.
Trong đấy cũng có skill brainstoring
luôn. Brain Storing
Brain
đấy. Thì dựa vào các skill và các ru các
workfollow đã thiết lập này thì mình đi
luôn vào thực hiện demo một
web landing page đi thực hiện luôn web
cho nó nhanh. Thì mình thực hiện bước
đầu tiên mình sẽ thường ấy là nếu mà ai
hay sử dụng skill quen không sử dụng
workfollow ấ thì mọi người cũng có thể
sử dụng được. Mọi người có thể gọi luôn
brainstoring. Brainstoring ra để sử dụng
thực hiện lên kế hoạch. Thực hiện lên kế
hoạch tặng
cho tôi một landing page. Landing
page để quảng bá sản phẩm.
Đây mọi người có thể dùng skill này hoặc
mọi người có thể dùng plan. Nếu mà mọi
người đã viết plan chuẩn thì đây mình
sục xộc xong rồi mình ghi plan ra. Thì
plan ở đây trước mình đã viết cái gì?
Vừa mình có giới cũng có giới thiệu qua
với mọi người rồi. Ở đây là mình đã thêm
một bước nữa trước khi mà lên
brainstoring để hiểu kỹ hơn về context
rồi kỹ hơn về repo mà hiện tại mình đang
có thì nó thực hiện sẽ đọc lại cái các
learning trước nó đã được học nếu mà
repo mọi người đã có. Và bước thứ hai
thì cũng nó sẽ gọi đến brainstoring
thôi. Nó sẽ gọi đến cái skill này để
thực hiện lên kế hoạch cho mình. Đây thì
thì mình sẽ thử xem là khi áp dụng
brinstoring thì nó sẽ đưa cho mình kết
quả gì nhá.
Đấy king face 1 brainstorming. Đấy nó
cũng giải thích là landing page khoảng
ba sản phẩm. Bước một sẽ load learning.
Đấy đúng đúng theo workfollow luôn.
Load learning liên quan xem là có
learning nào có thể học được không.
Khi đấy thì nó sẽ ờ không không học được
tại vì cái project này trống mà mình
chưa có thêm một file learning nào hết.
Cũng chưa làm gì với project này cả. Thì
đây thì sau khi nó thực hiện
brainstoring xong thì nó sẽ báo trước
khi bắt tay vào thiết kế. Đây mình có
thể đọc nó sẽ đưa ra cho mình những cái
câu hỏi
nó đưa cho mình những cái câu hỏi để
clear nhất được cái ý tưởng lên page của
mình là page gì các thứ. Đấy thì nó hỏi
mình bạn muốn có ba sản phẩm nào? Chọn
một hoặc chi tiết mô tả. Đây mình thử
đây mình chọn luôn. A tôi muốn khoảng ba
ứng dụng nếu mà mình muốn thêm vào nhá
mình đã chọn A rồi mình muốn thêm vào
khoảng ba ứng dụng gì kỹ càng đi. Tôi c
bảo tôi viết a vào xong viết tôi muốn ờ
quảng
bá ứng dụng
mobile
về dòng ờ
ừ
về dòng cleaner
rồi
Đây lúc này ví dụ lúc mình lên bừa
Google mình lấy một ý tượng đi để cho
web landing page nó đây Google Play
Cleaner
Đây mình có thể bảo lo thông tin 2A ghi
ra câu hỏi 2A
của tôi
ở trên này
vớt link vào đấy.
Đấy.
Cái 2 2. B 2B 2B.
Tính năng chính của app là gì? Dọn giác
tăng tốc loan. Đây 2B thì mình có thể
chọn 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 5
chọn hết
2B chọn cả hạn
C tại C
phong cách thiết kế mong muốn
neon
sáng tối chuyên nghiệp stake hiệu ứng
tôi sẽ chọn style phù hợp nhất
Ok.
Đấy, đã lấy được thông [âm nhạc] tin rồi
theo cái link mà tôi mô tả. Đây những
tổng hợp mọi người đọc kỹ những cái này
để
kết hợp được
nút landing page chỉ cần một trang duy
nhất download Google Play. Đấy thì ở đây
mình sẽ nhận đúng. Ok trên đã đúng đúng
mình ghi thế thôi.
Vì mình không muốn thêm bớ session nào
mà đây là kết quả mình đã ưng ý rồi thì
mình bảo đúng. Còn nếu mà bạn muốn thêm
bớt hoặc là muốn sửa gì thì mình có thể
sửa luôn. Ở đây mình báo nó là chẳng hạn
style mình không ưng là dark mode chẳng
hạn không thích neon thì mình sẽ báo là
chuyển cho tôi style khác hay gợi ý cho
tôi 10 style. Đấy các text text text thì
mình muốn chuyển đổi sang kiểu gì thì
mình có thể bảo lo chuyển sang hoặc gợi
ý cho tôi
gợi ý cho tôi text ổn định nhất
tối ưu nhất cho
tag này.
Đấy hiện tại giờ nó sẽ đang thình kinh.
>> [âm nhạc]
>> Đây thì sau khi thực hiện xong cái các
bước trên thì nó sẽ tạo được một plan
cho mình như thế này. Mình sẽ thực hiện
review qua. Nếu mà ổn thì mình sẽ
process tiếp cho AI agent thực hiện
tiếp.
Nếu mà không bạn thấy chưa ổn nhá thì
mình sẽ t luôn vào đây. Comment in mình
comment luôn vào đây để ai nó thực hiện
sửa lại plan này cho mình. Đấy mình đọc
mình đọc qua mình thấy ổn rồi. Process
tiếp để AI dực hiện tiếp.
>> [âm nhạc]
>> Rồi sau khi thực hiện xong plan chain
thì của AI agent đã đưa ra được kết quả
hoàn thành landing landing page phone
clean.
Đây mình truy cập vào xem kết quả ra sao
nhá.
Đây đã thực hiện review trước rồi.
Đây hiện tại đang có một lỗi ở đây.
Download này
sau đấy
cũng khá là đẹp rồi chứ.
Major
download free à
mình xem có được kết nối link này
tổng thể về team app
tex typography
rất là ổn
how it work
download install
tổng hợp các thông tin ở trên a Google
Play xuống đây. What you say? Đây là các
đánh giá của app.
Web này mình thấy khá là ổn rồi. Thì còn
một chút bấc nữa ở đây nữa thôi. Thì
tiện đây thì nếu có bấc ở đây thì mình
sẽ sử dụng luôn skill mà đã được vẽ và
thực hiện vẽ lại ảnh này với PNG thôi.
Không để ảnh
có
background như này được.
Để mình bảo nó bảo AI agent.
Đây mình sẽ accept lại cái đoạn code này
và thực hiện bảo sẽ feedback team bug
bấc cho tôi
đây. Mọi người có thể gõ chữ bớ nhá để
ra được rất nhiều các skill agent mình
có thể thực hiện chứ không bắt buộc là
sử dụng mỗi cái phbox và lật lệnh
mình ở đây có thể iOS debug agent này
hoặc là debuging state
strategy này b hunter này
đây nếu mọi người có làm web API thì có
thể sử dụng được cái API Fing B này
party này. Bry này. Đ đây mình sẽ sử
dụng tạo bug
để thực hiện team bug. Mình xin miêu tả
cái bấc đấy. Chụp ảnh và miêu tả.
Chụ ảnh lại
bỏ lô
hiện tại
page trên
page của tôi có
một dòng text kèm với button download
của một dòng text
cam
button download
bị
logo
của page đè lên thực hiện
tìm bớ
và sửa giúp tôi
đây để xem nó có sửa được không nhá
Mình đã cung cấp bấc khá chi tiết rồi.
Rồi đó là ba bước đã được fix đây. Giờ
mình sẽ kiểm tra lại nhá. Xem bước đ fix
th chưa.
Lên tạ đi. Rồi ok thực hiện reload lại.
Ok đã hết bớc.
mượt như s
rồi rất đẹp
đấy. Mình vào là mình cũng muốn tải luôn
ấy. Đây chỉ còn một lỗi nữa về ảnh thôi.
Thì cái ảnh này thì AI nó đang tự diệt
thì mình cũng có thể sửa được luôn nhá.
Để mình thử bảo sửa thử bảo ai nó sửa
xem có được không. Nếu mà không được thì
các bạn chịu khó sang bên
có thể là sang bên chat GVT hoặc là bên
nào nó chuyên về hình ảnh hơn để mình
gen hình ảnh này nhá. Xong rồi mình đưa
cái hình ảnh này vào lại project để cho
Aion nó xử lý thay cho luôn cho mình để
mình không phải thay. Đây còn đâu là bây
giờ mình sẽ thực hiện là bảo thằng này
nó vẽ lại cái ảnh này xem nó có ổn
không.
Đây mình bật lên ảnh này mình kéo lại
kéo đây cho nó và nó thực hiện xóa lên.
thực hiện.
Tôi sẽ thi kiểm tra xem nó có skill nào
về cái remove background không.
Remove background chẳng hạn. Background
đây không có chỉ có back end thôi.
No back end feedback không có. Vậy thì
mình cứ bảo bỏ thôi nhá. thực hiện xóa
nền đ nhẹ cho tôi
rất là đẹp
rồi. Ok mình Ctrl S lại nhá. Ctrl S lại
xong rồi quay lại page này.
Page đâu?
Đây reload lại xem. Rồi bây giờ ảnh đã
khá là đẹp rồi. Hài hóa với page mọi
người có thể căn chỉnh thêm cho nó to
thêm nào cho nó vừa ý hoặc xoay trái
xoay phải. Đấy thì sau khi sử dụng xong
AI để tạo landing page rồi thì mình sẽ
lên plan các thứ để tạo được một cái ban
landing page hoàn chỉnh. Rồi thì mình sẽ
phải đảm bảo nó sẽ không có bấc đúng
không? Thì mình sẽ thực hiện AI review
lại. Mình sẽ gõ code review ở đây. Code
review
mình sẽ bảo là thực hiện
review lại.
review lại xem code đã tối ư chưa giúp
tôi
accept thay đổi trên đi
để xem cái con AI agent này nó sẽ thực
hiện như nào nhá.
Đây tôi sẽ thực hiện review lại toàn bộ
code base. Đọc lại các file trước
rồi thực hiện review ra toàn bộ code
base. Tạo báo cáo.
Đây ở đây thì có những tím vẽ chín ISU
nhưng mà không có cái ISU nào nặng cao
cả. Đấy, ở đây thì sẽ có các si tầm
trùng mình có thể sửa hoặc là nếu mà
chưa gấp thì chưa cần sửa chỗ này. Đấy,
nó cũng lên cho mình một code review
mình có thể xem kỹ hơn ở trong này nữa.
Code đang báo bị làm sao đây. Summary sẽ
không có cái lỗi nào quá nguy hiểm cả.
Chỉ chỉ có ba lỗi tầm trung thôi.
Đọc kỹ hơn đ pha cod được index ra html
82. Đây đang f
priority.
Đây mọi người có thể review lại cái dòng
code à cái file này xong rồi bắt nó sửa
những cái lỗi nào mà nó cao quá nó bị
nghiêm trọng quá. Nếu mà chưa cần thiết
cảm thấy như thế là ổn rồi, như thế là
đủ dùng rồi thì thôi không cần đâu. Đấy
có thể ok hoàn thành. Sau khi hoàn thành
ở đây thì thường thì tôi sẽ sử dụng thêm
một bước nữa là
sử dụng thêm cái Asian AI learning này.
Thì ở bước vừa rồi mình tạo plan ấy. Thì
sau khi tạo xong plan thực XQ xong AI
agent nó có thì AI nó có hỏi luôn cái
bước đấy là bạn có thực muốn review
không? À bạn có muốn lưu lại AI Learning
không?
Đây
summary summary
xác nhận đúng chưa?
Tiện ứng dụng
thực hiện face 2
đây. Nếu mà nó quên nó không hỏi mình
ấy.
Đây là word follow rồi mà. Wordfollow
mình thực hiện đên một t rồi mà. Thế có
khi ai nó cũng bị mid là chuyện bình
thường. Thì đây mình đã tạo một cái
skill ở đây đó là cái à cái workfow AI
learning.
Thì trong này sẽ bắt con AI nó bent nó
sẽ tóm tắt lại cái conversion conversion
này của mình và sẽ thực hiện học lại
viết lại một file MD để sau đấy nếu mà
có những cái thay đổi cho con cho
phần page landing page này thì con agent
sẽ đọc vào đây trước để nó thực thi nó
hiểu được context ngữ cảnh hơn. Đây mình
sẽ tạo AI learning đây. Mình sẽ gọi
thằng này ra AI Learning. Đấy mình sẽ có
thể chỉ cần gọi như này thôi. Xong mình
enter để cho nó học để xem sau đấy nó
học xong thì nó sẽ như thế nào.
Đấy nó học được nó sẽ tạo file learning
mới này. Learning page
kiểm tra xem vẫn chưa tạo xong.
>> [âm nhạc]
>> Rồi đã tạo xong đã thực hiện học xong
cái
conversion trên
xem nào.
Đây AI agent nó thực hiện chắc là mình
tạo được dẫn nhầm đọc lại xem nào. A
tìm chỗ P.
Đây bây gi mình đang viết nhầm là lưu
vào agent thì nó đang lưu và tạo ra một
cái agent s đuôi sở cuối. Sau đấy mình
sẽ chỉnh lại value thì nó sẽ tạo lên đây
cho mình. Đấy
xõ cái này đi thì lúc này đọc lại xem
xem cáiing page này nó học được những
cái gì.
Architecture
Dark neon planning page design system
đấy. Ngày bao nhiêu chi tiết CS tổ chức
thứ tự
single page
đấy bug và solution
đấy nó lưu luôn lại cả bug mà b cách
giải quyết này. CS CSS này. Vâng và cách
đây là cách làm như nào? How to
tạo landing page D neon cho app mobile
xóa nền bằng ảnh Python ok nó có lưu lại
luôn cái này này
và đây
đây nó lưu th lại hết thông tin cho mình
để sau nếu mà mình có gặp lỗi hoặc này
hoặc là cần sửa những cái gì lúc đấy nó
chỉ cần đọc và landing page thôi là nó
biết là mình sẽ đã thực hiện như thế nào
để mà AI nó sẽ tối ưu hơn.
Đấy thì bên trên bên trên là toàn bộ
hướng dẫn của mình về cách sử dụng con
AI agent của bên Google Anti Gravity.
Nếu mọi người thấy hay thì cho mình một
like nhé.